all right who's the most intimidating
Robbie Coltrane Alan Rickman Richard
Harris Michael gambone
who's who who's the most intimidating
when they walked on site you're like oh
boy I think at first Alan Rickman
um because he was so Snape you know he
wanted us to fear Him
um and it he did a very good job at it
but you could tell that he was kind of
having fun with it too which I then
later kind of realized as I kind of grew
up I was like wait a minute you're like
definitely you know enjoying this kind
of thing and actually when you I had the
confidence to speak to him he was such a
like soft and lovely human bad voice
yeah can you still hear that voice it's
so deep what are you doing or something
it was like a deep I can't even do it I
know but as you passed him in the uh
Hawaii did he ever do funny things like
just quickly this kind of look at it all
would just say things in a really Snape
voice like
um but using my name in a sentence you
know you're like oh my gosh
um and then Michael Michael Gambon was
like
he was kind of the same like you think
he's really scaring at first you're like
Dumbledore you know but then he too had
this very soft like humorous like cheeky
nature to him too which like upon having
the opportunity to have more scenes you
know with him that weren't like massive
Great Hall scenes you're like oh you're
like you're fine you know you're a human
too so that was always fun
um when that you still had you know you
still definitely hold them on this
pedestal but they kind of you know they
soften and become more human sure like
yeah hey there folks it's Michael
Rosenbaum and boy have I got a huge
announcement for you this has been a
long time comment and it's finally here
I'm doing a live podcast my podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum is
going live yeah for the first time ever
on Wednesday October 11th at the iconic
Regent in Los Angeles and guess what I'm
Not Gonna Be Alone
um we're bringing a guest you might
remember he's been on the podcast he's a
friend of the show the one the only
Zachary Levi we're gonna catch up on
life and mental health and we're gonna
have a really good time with all of you
I think you know that we're gonna make
it a lot of fun we're planning a q a
maybe some fun games other exclusive
stuff you're only going to get by seeing
it live we're even hosting a VIP meet
and greet for a small number of people
before the show begins grab your tickets
mark your calendars and get ready for
the night of laughs insights and
Unforgettable moments tickets are
limited so don't miss your chance to
join us on October 11th at the Regent in
Los Angeles get your tickets now at
insideofulive.com this is going to be an
epic night so if you're in the area come
out and I'll see you there who was who
took their work most seriously they were
they just were in the zone always they
stayed in their character or they you
know they they were friendly or whatever
but they were in their character that
you could remember they go oh okay